the highly anticipated release of james
gunn's half sequel half reboot the
suicide squad
has wild audiences and critics alike
earning the movie a 91
certified fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes
guns movie delivers on its promise of
intense r-rated violence and off-kilter
humor another cast that includes
returning dc stewards and a whole host
of new squad members
the 2021 film finds amanda waller
leading two teams of crazy criminals to
take down a nazi era laboratory called
yotenheim which is rumored to be the
home base of a secret experiment known
as project starfish
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for god's sake following the critical
disaster that was 2016 suicide squad
there seemed to be nowhere to go but up
the original film was highly profitable
but maybe this time they could make a
movie
most people actually liked the good news
for film fans is the suicide squad
appears to have succeeded when it comes
to quality
winning over audiences and critics alike
the bad news is
this one doesn't seem to be making any
money or at least nowhere near as much
money as the 2016 one did
during its first weekend the new movie
made approximately 26.5 million dollars
at the domestic box office falling short
of expectations that predicted it making
at least 30 million dollars
at the start so what's happened
according to box office analysts the
rise in the delta variant of covet 19
is likely the most significant factor in
why the suicide squad fell
short of his projected box office return
while the beginning of the summer saw
many businesses reopening
states relaxing their mask guidelines
and daily life returning to some form of
normalcy
all that has been challenged recently by
media coverage of the contagious covet
19 variants
according to data from uc davis health
as of july 22
2021 almost 80 percent of the
organization's covert patients
had the delta variant while the cdc
reported a higher percentage at the same
time
the rise in the delta variant has caused
the cdc and many businesses to revert to
previous mass and safety guidelines
suggesting that people need to be more
careful about the possible spread of the
virus
through indoor activities this likely
led many to postpone any plans to visit
a movie theater
considering the high rate of
transmission often found in that
environment
while it's unclear exactly how much the
delta variant contributed to the suicide
squad's box office shortcomings
it was clearly an influence one of the
other main reasons for hollywood's lower
box office returns in 2021
has been the shift from theatrical
releases to streaming like every other
recent warner brothers release the
suicide squad was released
simultaneously in theaters
and on hbo max over the last year or so
that streaming platform has given people
who are unable to go to the theater
a chance to catch the latest big
releases from the comfort of their own
home
other companies such as walt disney
studios are also using a mixed
theatrical and digital release system
though it's unclear how this will change
going forward and whether it's
financially sustainable for the studio
themselves
because of this recent trend as well as
the ongoing shift over the past decade
to more streamable content
it's no longer possible to rely on the
box office as the best way to measure
the success of a new release
even streaming figures are a little up
in the air for example the analytics
company samba tv
has suggested that around 2.8 million us
households
watch the suicide squad on hbo max on
opening weekend
but it's difficult to work out or that
might have translated into ticket sales
considering a household can contain
multiple people nonetheless
deadline reports that the movie at least
holds the distinction of having the top
grossing r-rated opening
for a movie in the pandemic era but that
may be a cold comfort when comparing the
receipts to the movie's 185 million
dollar budget
with so many mixed signals it's hard to
argue that the suicide squad is a
bonafide box office flop
even after you consider those low
returns but it doesn't appear to have
been a roaring success either
at the very least the movie's a good one
we can give them a hand for that
and yes that is your hand very good
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you